the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so we're ready to begin
lecture ten and what I'm going to begin
with is by finishing up some things from
last time we'll talk about
approximations and I want to fill in a
number of comments and get you a little
bit more oriented in the in the point of
view that I'm trying to express about
approximations so first of all I want to
remind you of the actual applied example
that I wrote down last time
so that was this business here there was
something from special relativity and
the approximation that we used was the
linear approximation with a minus 1/2
power that comes out to be T times 1
plus 1/2 V squared over C squared now
the point I want to reiterate why this
is a useful way of thinking of things
and why this is that this comes up in
real life why this is maybe more
important than everything that I've
taught you about technically so far so
first of all what this is telling us is
the change in T divided by T if you do
the arithmetic here and subtract T
that's that's using the change in T as T
prime minus T here if you work that out
this is approximately the same as 1/2 V
squared over C squared so what is this
saying this is saying that if you have
this satellite which is going at speed V
and little C is the speed of light then
the change in the watch they down here
on earth relative to the time on the
satellite is going to be proportional to
this ratio here so physically this makes
sense this is time divided by time and
this is velocity squared divided by
velocity squared so in each case the
unit's divide out so this is a
dimensionless
quantity and this is a dimensionless
quantity and the only point here that
we're trying to make is just this notion
of proportionality so I want to write
this down just in it's sorry so the
error fraction if you like which is sort
of the number of significant digits that
we have in our measurement is
proportional in this case to this
quantity it happens to be proportional
to this this quantity here and the
factor is happens to be 1/2 all right so
these proportionality factors are what
we're looking for their rates of change
the rate of change of something with
respect to something else now on your
homework you have something rather
similar to this so in problem on part 2b
part 2 problem 1 there's the speed of a
pitch right and the speed of the pitch
is changing depending on how high the
mound is and the point here is that
that's approximately proportional to the
change in the height of the mound in
that problem we had this Delta H that
was the X variable in that problem and
what you're trying to figure out is what
the constant of proportionality is
that's that's what you're aiming for in
this problem so there's a linear
relationship approximately to all
intents and purposes this is an equality
because the lower order terms are
unimportant for the problem just is over
here this function is a little bit
complicated this function is a little
more simple for the purposes of this
problem they're the same because there's
the the errors are negligible for the
particular problem that we're working on
so we might as well work with the
simpler relationship and similarly over
here so you could do this with in this
case with square roots it's not so hard
here with reciprocals of square roots
it's also not terribly hard to do it
numerically and the reason why we're not
doing it numeric
is that as I say this is a something
that happens all across engineering
people are looking for these linear
relationships between the change in some
input and the change in the output and
if you don't make these simplifications
then when you get say a dozen of them
together you can't figure out what's
going on in this case the design of the
satellite it's very important this speed
actually isn't just one speed because
it's the relative speed of you to the
the the satellite and you might be it it
did is it depends on your angle of sight
with the satellite what the speed is so
it varies quite a bit so you really need
this rule of thumb then there are all
kinds of other considerations in this
question like for example there's the
fact that we're sitting on earth and so
we're rotating around what's called a
non inertial frame so there's the
question of that acceleration there's
the question that the gravity the I
experience here on earth is not the same
as up at the satellite and that also
creates a difference in time as a result
of general relativity so all of these
considerations come down to formulas
which are this complicated or maybe a
tiny bit more not really that much and
then people simplify them enormous ly to
these very simple-minded rules and then
they keep track of what's going on so so
in order to design the system you must
make these simplifications otherwise you
can't even think about what's going on I
mean that this this comes up in
everything and weather forecasting
economic forecasting figuring out
whether there's going to be an asteroid
that's going to hit the earth these
every every single one of these things
involves dozens of these considerations
okay there was a question that I saw
here yes
yeah so in basically any problem where
you have a derivative the rate of change
also depends on what the base point is
that's the question you're saying
doesn't this Delta V also depend I had a
base point in that problem I happen to
decide that pitchers pitch on average
about 90 miles an hour whereas in fact
some pitchers pitch at 100 miles an hour
some pitch at 80 miles an hour and of
course they vary the speed of the pitch
and so this varies a little bit
in fact that's sort of a second-order
effect it does change the constant of
proportionality it's a rate of change at
a different base point which we're
considering fixed okay in fact if you if
that's sort of a second-order effect
when you when you actually do the
computations where you discover is it
doesn't make that much difference to the
to the a and that's something that you
get from experience that it turns out
that which things matter in which things
don't and yet again that's exactly the
same sort of consideration but at the
next order of what I'm talking about
here is you have to have enough
experience with numbers to know that if
you take if you vary something a little
bit it's not going to change the answer
that you're looking for very much and
that's exactly the the point that I'm
making so I can't make them all at once
all such points all right so so that's
my my pitch for for understanding things
from this point of view now we're going
to go on now to two quadratic
approximations which are a little more
complicated so we talked a little bit
about this last time but I didn't finish
so I want to finish up this this up and
the first thing that I should say is
that you use these use these when the
linear approximation is not enough okay
so you know that's something that you
really need to get a little experience
with in economics I told you they use
logarithms so sometimes they use log
linear functions sometimes they use log
quadratic functions when the log lynnie
ones don't work so most modeling and
economics is with log quadratic
functions and if you made it any more
complicated than that it's useless and
it's a mess and people don't do it so
they stick with the quadratic ones
typically alright so the basic formula
here and I'm going to take the base
point to be zero is that f of X is
approximately f of 0 plus F prime of 0
times X that's the linear part plus this
extra term which is f double prime of 0
divided by 2 x squared and this is
supposed to work for X near 0 ok
so I've chosen the base point as simply
as possible right so here's more or less
where we left off last time and one
thing that I said I was going to going
to explain which I will now is why it's
1/2 F double prime of 0 so we need to
know need to know that so let's let's
work that out here first of all so I'm
just going to do it by example so if you
like the answer is just well what
happens when you have a parabola a
parabola is a quadratic it had better
it's quadratic approximation to better
be itself it's got to be the best one so
it's got to be itself so this formula if
it's going to work has to work on the
butt on the nose for quadratic functions
so let's take a look if I differentiate
I get B plus 2 C X if I differentiate a
second time I get to C and now let's
let's plug it in well we can recover
what is it that we want to recover we
want to recover these numbers a B and C
using the derivatives evaluated at 0 so
of so let's see it's pretty easy
actually F of 0 is a that's on the nose
if you plug in x equals 0 here these
terms drop out you get a and now F prime
of 0 whoops that was wrong
so I wrote F Prime but what I meant was
F all right so F of 0 is a let's back up
F of 0 is a so if I plug in x equals 0 I
get a alright now F prime of 0 that's
this next formula here F prime of 0 I
plug in zero here and I get B that's
also good and that's exactly what the
linear approximation is supposed to be
but now you notice F double prime is 2 C
so to recover C I better take half of it
and that's it that's that's the reason
there's no chance that any other formula
could work and this one does alright so
that's the explanation for the formula
and now I remind you that I had a
collection of basic formulas written on
the board and I want to just make sure
we know all of them again so first of
all there was sine X is approximately X
cosine X is approximately 1 minus 1/2 x
squared and e to the X is approximately
1 plus x plus 1/2 x squared so those
were three that I mentioned last time
and again this is all for X near 0 all
for X near 0 only these are wildly wrong
far away but near 0 there there nice
good quadratic approximations the other
two approximations that I want to
mention are the logarithm and we use the
base point shifted so so we can put it
at X near 0 and this one sorry this is
an approximately equal sign there it
turns out to be X minus 1/2 x squared
and the last one is 1 plus X to the
power R which turns out to be 1 plus rx
plus R times R minus 1/2 x squared
now eventually your mind will converge
on all of these and you'll find them
relatively easy to memorize but it'll
take some getting used to and I'm not
claiming that you should recognize them
and understand them all now but I'm
going to put a giant box around this
yeah yeah so the question was you get
all of these that you use that equation
that's exactly what I'm going to do so I
already did it actually for these three
last time but I didn't do it yet for
these two all right but I will do it in
about of two minutes well maybe five
minutes but first I want to explain just
just a few things about these okay all
right they all follow from the from the
basic formula in fact that one deserves
a pink box too doesn't now it's pretty
important all right yeah maybe even some
little sparkles all right okay so that's
that's pretty important all right almost
as important is the more basic one
without without this term here all right
so now let me let me just tell you a
little bit more about the significance
again this is just to reinforce
something that we've already done but
it's closely related to what you're
doing on your problem set so it's it's
worth you your while to to recall this
so there's this expression that we were
dealing with and we talked about it in
lecture and we showed that this tends to
tends to e as K goes to infinity all
right so that's what we showed in
lecture and the way that we did that was
we took the logarithm and we wrote it as
K times sorry the logarithm of 1 plus 1
over K all right and then we evaluated
the limit of this now I want to do this
limit again using linear approximation
to show you how easy it is if you just
remember the linear approximation and
then we'll explain where the quadratic
approximation comes in so I claim that
this is approximately equal to K times 1
over K now why is that well that's just
this linear approximation so what did I
use here I used log of 1 plus X is
approximately X for X is equal to 1 over
K all right that's what I used in this
approximation here and that's the linear
approximation to the natural logarithm
and this number is relatively easy to
evaluate I know how to do it it's equal
to 1 all right that's the same well so
where does this work
this works where this thing is near zero
which is when K is going to infinity
this thing is working only when K is
going to infinity so what it's really
saying this approximation formulas it's
really saying that as we go to infinity
and K this thing is going to 1 all right
as K goes to infinity so that's that's
what it's saying that's the substance
there and that's how we want to use it
in many instances to just to evaluate
limits we also want to realize that it's
nearby when K is pretty large like a
hundred or something like that
now so that's the idea of the linear
approximation now if you want to get the
rate of convergence here so the rate of
what's called convergence so convergence
means how fast this is going towards
that what I have to do is take the
difference I have to take log a K and I
have to subtract one from it and I know
that this is going to zero and the
question is how big is this if we want
it to be very small and the answer we're
going to get so the answer just uses the
quadratic approximation so if I just
have a little bit more detail than this
expression here in other words I have
the next higher order term this is like
1 over K this is like 1 over K squared
then I can understand how big the
difference is between the expression
that I've got in its limit all right so
that's what's on your homework right
this is on your problem set ok so that
is more or less an explanation for one
of the things that quadratic
approximations are good for and I'm
going to give you one more illustration
one more illustration and then we'll
will actually check these formulas yeah
another question
the quiz a very good question here when
they which in this case means maybe me
when I give you a question does one
specify whether you want to use a linear
or quadratic approximation the answer is
in in real life when you're faced with a
problem like this where some satellite
is orbiting and you want to know the
effects of gravity or something like
that nobody is going to tell you
anything they're not even going to tell
you whether a linear approximation is
relevant or a quadratic or anything so
you're you're on your own when I give
you a question at least for right now
I'm always going to tell you but as time
goes on I'd like you to get used to when
it's enough to use get away with a
linear approximation and you should only
use a quadratic approximation if
somebody forces you to you should always
start with trying with the linear one
because the quadratic ones are much more
complicated as you'll see in this next
example okay so the example that I want
to use is you're going to be stuck with
it because I'm asking for the quadratic
so we're going to find the quadratic
approximation near for X near 0 to what
well this is the same function that we
used in the last lecture I think this
was it e to the minus 3x 1 plus X to the
minus 1/2 okay so unfortunately I stuck
it in the in the wrong place to be able
to fit this very long formula here so
I'm going to I'm going to switch it
alright I'm just going to write it here
and we're going to just do the
approximation all right
so we're going to say quadratic in
parenthesis and we'll say X near 0 all
right so that's what I want so now
here's what I have to do well I have to
write in the quadratic approximation for
e to the minus 3x and I'm going to use
this formula right here and so that's 1
plus -3 X plus -3 X the quantity squared
over 2 the other factor I'm going to
have to use this formula down here
because R is minus 1/2 and so that's a 1
minus 1/2 X plus 1/2 times minus 1/2
times minus 3 halves x squared all right
so this is the this is the R term and
this is the R minus 1 term and now I'm
going to do something which is the only
good thing about quadratic
approximations they're messy they're
long there's nothing particularly good
about them but there is one good thing
about them which is that you always get
to ignore the higher order terms so even
though this looks like a very ugly
multiplication I can do it in my head
just watching it all right because I get
a 1 times 1 I'm forced with that term
here all right and then I get the cross
terms which are linear which is minus 3x
minus 1/2 X we already did that when we
calculated the linear approximation so
that's this times the 1 and this times
that 1 and now I have 3 cross terms
which are quadratic so one of them is
these two linear terms of multiplying so
that's plus 3 halves x squared that's
minus 3 times minus 1/2
and then there's this term multiplying
the one that's plus nine halves x
squared and then there's one last term
which is this monster here multiplying 1
and that is minus 3/8 okay so the great
thing is we drop X cubed x to the fourth
etc terms yeah okay well so copy it down
and you work it out as I'm doing it now
all right so what I did is I multiplied
one by one I'm using the distributive
law here that was this one I multiplied
this 3x by this one that was that term I
multiplied this by this that's that term
and then I multiplied this by this in
other words two x terms that gave me an
x squared and a minus three times a
minus 1/2 and I'm going to stop at that
point because the point is it's just all
the rest of the terms that come up now
the reason the only reason why it's easy
is that I only have to go up two x
squared terms I don't have to do the
higher ones
another question way back here yeah
right there
good why do I get to draw all our chums
so that's because the situation where
I'm going to apply this is a situation
in which X is say 1/100 okay so here is
about a hundred here's something which
is on the order of a hundred this is on
the order of a hundred squared 100
squared all of these terms
now these cubic and quartic terms are of
the order of 1/100 cubed that's ten to
the minus sixth and I'm the point is
that I'm not claiming that I have an
exact answer and I'm going to drop
things of that order of magnitude
all right so I'm saving everything up to
four decimal places I'm throwing away
things which are six decimal places out
does that does that answer your question
all right so that's the situation and
now you can combine the terms I mean
it's not very impressive here this is
equal to one minus seven halves X maybe
plus 51 eight x squared if I made that
if those minus signs hadn't canceled I
would have gotten the wrong answer here
anyway so so this is a two here sorry
seven halves right this is the linear
approximation that we got last time and
here's the extra information that we got
from this calculation which is this
fifty-one eighth term right you have to
accept that there's a certain degree of
complexity to this problem and the
answer is sufficiently complicated so it
can't be less arithmetic because we get
this peculiar of 51 eight there all
right so you one of the things to
realize is that these kinds of problems
because they involve many many terms are
always going to involve a little bit of
complicated arithmetic
okay last little bit I did promise you
that I was going to derive these two
relations as I said I did the ones in
the left column so let's carry that out
and as someone just pointed out it all
comes from this formula here so let's
just check it so we'll start with the
log function this is the function f and
then F prime is 1 over 1 plus X and F
double Prime
so this is f Prime this is f double
prime is minus 1 over 1 plus x squared
and now I have to plug in x equals 0 so
at x equals 0 this is log of 1 which is
0 so this is at x equals 0 I'm getting 0
here I plug in 0 and I get 1 and here I
plug in 0 and I get negative 1 so now I
go and I look up at that formula which
is way in that upper corner there and I
see that the coefficient on the constant
is 0 the coefficient on X is 1 and then
the other coefficient the very last one
is minus 1/2 so this is the minus 1 here
and then in the formula there's a 2 in
the denominator so it's 1/2 of whatever
I get for the second derivative at 0 all
right so this is the approximation
formula which is way up in that corner
there
all right similarly if I do it for 1
plus X to the power R I have to
differentiate that I get R 1 plus X to
the R minus 1 and then R times R minus 1
X plus 1 to the R minus 2 so here are
the derivatives and so if I evaluate
them at x equals 0 I get 1 that's 1 to
the our powers 1 and here I get bar 1 to
the R minus 1 times R and here I plug in
x equals 0 and I get R times R minus
so again the pattern is right above it
here the one is there the R is there and
then instead of R times R minus one
I have half that for the coefficient
all right so these are just examples
obviously if we had a more complicated
function we might carry this out but as
a practical matter we try to stick with
the ones in the pink box and just use
algebra to get other formulas okay all
right so so I want to shift gears now
and and treat the subject that was
supposed to be this lecture and we're
we're not quite caught up but we will
try to do our best to do as much as we
can today so the next topic is curve
sketching and so let's get started with
that
okay so now happily in this subject
there's there are more pictures and it's
a little bit more geometric and there's
relatively little computation so let's
hope we can we can we can do this so so
I want to so here we go we'll start with
curve sketching and the goal here ooh
you know so that's like liner the last
time is okay that's kind of sketchy
spelling isn't it
yeah there's certain kinds of things
which I can't spell all right sketching
all right so here's our goal our goal is
to draw the graph of F using F Prime and
F double Prime
whether they're positive or negative
okay so that's it this is the the goal
here however there is a big warning that
I want to give you and this is one that
unfortunately I now have to make you
unlearn especially those of you who've
actually had a little bit of calculus
before I want to make you unlearn some
of your instincts that you develop so
this will be harder for those of you who
have actually done this before all right
but for the rest of you it will be
relatively easy which is don't
abandon your precalculus skills and
common sense okay so there's a great
deal of common sense in this and it
actually Trump's some of the calculus
the calculus just fills in what you
didn't quite know yet so I will try to
illustrate this and because we're
running a bit late I won't get to the
some of the main punch lines until next
lecture but I want you to do it so for
now I'm just going to tell you about the
general principles and in the process
I'm going to introduce the terminology
what it just the words that we need to
use to describe what it is that we're
doing and there's also a certain amount
of carelessness with that in many of the
treatments that you'll see and a lot of
hastiness so that just be a little
patient and we will we will we will do
this all right so the first principle is
the following if f prime is positive
then F is increasing that's a
straightforward idea and it's closely
related to this tangent line
approximation or the linear
approximation that I just did you can
just imagine here's the tangent line
here's the function and if the tangent
line is pointing up then the function is
also going up too so that's all that's
going on here
similarly if F prime is negative then F
is decreasing and that's the basic idea
now the second step is also fairly
straightforward it's just a second-order
effect of the same type if you have F
double prime is positive then that means
that F prime is increasing
that's the same principle applied one
step up right because
f double prime is positive that means
it's the derivative of F Prime so so
it's the same principle just repeated
and now I just want to draw a picture of
this okay
here's a picture of it I claim and it
looks like something's going down and I
did that on purpose
but there is something that's increasing
here which is the slope is very steep
negative here and it's less steep
negative over here so we have the slope
which is some negative numbers say
negative 4 and here it's negative 3 all
right so it's increasing it's getting
less negative and maybe eventually it'll
curve up the other way and this is a
picture of what I'm what I'm talking
about here that's what it means to say
that F prime is increasing the slope is
getting larger and the way to describe a
curve like this is that it's concave so
f is concave up and similarly F double
prime negative is going to be the same
thing as f concave or implies F concave
down alright so those are the those are
the ways in which derivatives will help
us qualitatively to draw graphs but as I
said before we still have to use our a
little bit of common sense when we draw
the graphs these are just the additional
bits of help that we have from calculus
and drawing pictures
so I'm going to go through one example
to introduce all the notations and then
eventually so probably at the beginning
of next time I'll give you a systematic
strategy that's going to work when what
I'm describing now goes wrong or a
little bit wrong so let's begin with a
straightforward example so the first
example that I'll give you is the
function f of X is equal to 3x minus X
cubed just as I said to be able to
introduce all the notations now if you
differentiate it you get 3 minus 3x
squared and I can factor that right this
is 3 times 1 minus x times 1 plus X ok
and so I can decide whether the
derivative is positive or negative
easily enough namely just staring at
this I can see that when negative 1 is
less than X is less than 1 in that range
they're both these numbers both these
factors are positive 1 minus X is a
positive number and 1 plus X is a
positive number so in this range f prime
of X is positive so this thing is so f
is increasing and similarly in the other
ranges if X is very very large this
becomes if it crosses 1 in fact this
becomes this factor becomes negative and
this one stays positive so when X is
bigger than 1 we have that F prime of X
is negative and so f is decreasing
and the same thing goes for the other
side when it's less than negative one
that also works this way because it's
less than negative one this number
factor is positive but the other one is
negative
all right so in both of these cases we
get that it's decreasing so now here's
the schematic picture of this function
so here's negative one here's one it's
going to go down up down alright that's
what it's doing maybe I'll just leave it
alone like this all right that's what it
looks like so this is this is the kind
of information we can get right off the
bat and you notice immediately that it's
very important from the features of the
function the sort of key features of the
function that we see here are these two
places all right maybe I'll even mark
them in a like this and these things are
turning points okay now so so what are
they well they're just they're just the
points where the derivative changes sign
where it's it's negative here and it's
positive there so there it must be zero
so we have a definition and this is the
most important definition in this
subject which is that if f prime of X
zero is equal to zero we call that's
zero a critical point okay the word
turning-point is not used just because
in fact it doesn't have to turn around
at those points but certainly if it
turns around then this will happen and
we also have another notation which is
the number y 0 which is f of X
zero is called a critical value all
right so these are the these are the key
numbers that we're going to have to work
out in order to understand what the
function looks like
okay so what I'm going to do is just
plot them we're going to plot the
critical points and the values well we
found the critical points relatively
easily I didn't write it down here but
it's pretty obvious if you set f of X
equal to zero that implies that 1 minus
x times 1 plus x is 0 which implies that
X is plus or minus 1 so those are known
as the critical points and now in order
to get the critical values here I have
to plug in F of 1 for instance the
function is 3x minus x cube so this is 3
times 1 minus 1 cubed which is 2 and F
of minus 1 which is 3 times minus 1
minus minus 1 cubed which is minus 2 and
so I can plot the function here so here
is the point negative 1 and here's up
here is 2 so this is whoops which one is
it yeah this is negative 1 so it's down
here I guess so it's negative 1 negative
2 and then over here I have the point 1
2 all right
now what information do I get from so
I've now plotted to entry I claim very
interesting points what information do I
get from this the answer is I know
something very nearby because I've
already checked that the thing is coming
down from the left and coming back up
and so it must be shaped like this over
here the tangent line is is 0 it's going
to be level there and similarly over
here it's going to do that so this is
what we know so far based on what we've
computed
question the question is what happens if
there's a sharp corner and the answer is
calculus is it's not called a critical
point it's as something else and it's a
very important point - all right and we
will be discussing those kinds of points
they're much more dramatic instances of
that that's part of what we're going to
we're going to say but I just want to
save that all right we will be
discussing that yeah question the
question that was asked was how did I
know at the critical point that it's
concave down over here and concave up
over here the answer is that I actually
did not use the second derivative yet
what I used is another piece of
information I use the information that I
derived over here that F prime is
positive where F prime is positive and
where it's negative so what I know is
that the graph is going down to the left
of minus 1 it's going up to the right
here it's going up here and it's going
down there I did not use the second
derivative I used the first derivative
okay but I didn't just use the fact that
there was that there was a turning point
here I went well so actually I was using
the fact that it was a turning point I
wasn't using the fact that it was it had
a second derivative though okay for now
you can also see it by the second
derivative as well
all right now so now the next thing that
that I'd like to do I need to finish off
this graph and I just want to do it a
little bit carefully here in the in the
order that that is is reasonable now you
might happen to notice and there's
nothing wrong with this so so let's even
fill in a guess okay in order to fill in
yes though and have it be even vaguely
right I do have to notice that this
think wrought this function crosses the
origin right the function f of X is 3x
minus X cubed happens to also have the
property that F of 0 is equal to 0 as
again common sense you're allowed to use
your common sense you're allowed to
notice a value of the function and put
it in ok so there's nothing wrong with
that
if you happen to have such a value so
now we can guess what our function is
going to look like it's going to maybe
come down like this come up like this
and come down like this that could be
what it looks like but you know another
possibility is it sort of comes along
here and goes out that way comes along
here goes out that way who knows it
happens by the way that it's an odd
function right these are all odd powers
so actually it's symmetric on the right
half and the left half and crosses at 0
so everything that we do on the right is
going to be the same as what happens on
the left that's another piece of common
sense you want to make use of that as
much as possible whenever you're drawing
anything you don't want to throw out
information so this function happens to
be odd odd and f of 0 is equal to 0 I'm
considering those to be kinds of
precalculus skills that I want you to
use as much as you can so now here's the
first feature which is unfortunately
ignored in in most discussions of
functions and it's strange because
nowadays we have graphing things and
it's really the only part of the
exercise that you couldn't do at least
on this relatively simple minded level
without a with a graphing calculator and
that is what I would call the annex of
the problem so what happens off the
screen is the question and that
basically is the theoretical part of the
problem that you have to address you can
program this you can draw all the
pictures that you want but what you
won't see is what's off the screen you
need to know something too
figure out what's off the screen so in
this case I'm talking about what's off
the screen going to the right or going
to the left okay so let's check the ends
so here let's just take a look we have
the function f of X which is sorry 3x
minus X cubed again this is a
precalculus sort of thing and we're
imagining now let's just do X goes to
plus infinity so what happens here when
X is gigantic this term is is is
completely negligible right and it just
behaves like minus X cubed which goes to
minus infinity as X goes to plus
infinity and similarly f of X goes to
plus infinity if X goes to minus
infinity all right now let me pull down
this picture again and show you what
piece of the information we've got we
now know that it is heading up this way
it doesn't go like this it goes up like
that and I'm going to put an arrow for
it and it's going down like this alright
heading down to minus infinity as X goes
out farther to the right and going out
to plus infinity as X goes farther to
the left all right
so now there's there's hardly anything
left of this function to to describe
there's there's really nothing left
except maybe decoration and we kind of
like that decoration so we will we will
we will pay attention to it and to do
that we'll have to check the second
derivative so if we differentiate a
second time the first derivative was
remember 3 minus 3x squared so the
second derivative is minus 6x all right
so now we notice that F double prime of
X is negative if X is positive
and f double prime of X is positive if X
is negative and so in this part it's
concave down and in this part it's
concave up and now I'm going to switch
the boards so that you'll and drawed and
you see that it's it's it was begging to
be this way right it wasn't it was right
so will will fill in the rest of it here
maybe in a nice color here so this is
the whole graph and this is the correct
graph it comes down in one swoop down
here and comes up here and then it
changes to concave down right at the
origin alright so this point is of
interest not only because it's the place
where it crosses the axis but it's also
what's called an inflection point
inflection point that's a point where
because f double-prime at that place is
equal to 0 all right so it's a place
where the where the second derivative is
0 those we also consider those to be
interesting points now so let me just
make one closing remark here which is
that all of these this information fits
together and we're going to have much
much harder examples of this where
you'll actually have to think about
what's going on but there's a lot of
stuff protecting you and functions will
behave themselves and turn around
appropriately anyway we'll talk about it
next time